I'm in the business of safeguarding
secrets and this includes your secrets
cryptographers are the first line of
defense in an ongoing war that's been
raging for centuries a war between code
makers and code breakers and this is a
war on information the modern
battlefield for information is digital
and it wages across your phones your
computers and the Internet our job is to
create systems that scramble your emails
and credit card numbers your phone calls
and text messages and that includes
those saucy selfies so that all of these
information can only be descrambled by
the recipient that it's intended for now
until very recently we thought we'd won
this war for good right now
each of your smartphones is using
encryption that we thought was
unbreakable and it was going to remain
that way we were wrong because quantum
computers are coming and they're going
to change the game completely throughout
history cryptography and code breaking
has always been this game of cat and
mouse back in the 1500s Queen Mary the
Scots thought she was sending encrypted
letters that only her soldiers could
decipher but Queen Elizabeth of England
she had code breakers that were all over
it they decrypted Mary's letters saw
that she was attempting to assassinate
Elizabeth and subsequently they chopped
Mary's head off a few centuries later in
world war two the nazis communicated
using the enigma code a much more
complicated encryption scheme that they
thought was unbreakable but then good
old alan cheering the same guy who
invented what we now call the modern
computer he built a machine and used it
to break enigma he deciphered the German
messages and help to bring Hitler and
his Third Reich to a halt and so the
stories go on throughout the centuries
cryptographers improve their encryption
and then codebreakers fight back and
they find a way to break it this Wars
gone back and forth and it's been pretty
neck-and-neck that was until the 1970s
when some cryptographers made a huge
breakthrough they discovered an
extremely powerful way to do encryption
called public key cryptography now
unlike all of the prior methods used
throughout history it doesn't require
that the two parties that want to send
each other confidential information have
exchanged the secret key beforehand the
magic of public key cryptography is that
it allows us to connect securely with
anyone in the world whether we've
exchanged data before or not and to do
it so fast that you and I don't even
realize that it's happening whether
you're texting your mate to catch up for
a beer or you're a bank that's
transferring billions of dollars to
another bank modern encryption enables
us to send data that can be secured in a
matter of milliseconds the brilliant
idea that makes this magic possible it
relies on hard mathematical problems
cryptographers are deeply interested in
things that calculators can't do for
example calculators can multiply any two
numbers you like no matter how big the
size but going back the other way
starting with the product and then
asking which two numbers multiply to
give this one that's actually a really
hard problem if I asked you to find
which two-digit numbers multiply to give
851 even with a calculator most people
in this room would have a hard time
finding the answer by the time I'm
finished this talk and if I make the
numbers a little larger then there's no
calculator on earth that can do this in
fact even the world's fastest
supercomputer would take longer than the
life age of the universe to find the two
numbers that multiply to give this one
and this problem called integer
factorization is exactly what each of
your smartphones and laptops is using
right now to keep your data secure this
is the basis of modern encryption
and the fact that all of the computing
power on the planet combined can't solve
it that's the reason we cryptographers
thought we'd found a way to stay ahead
of the codebreakers for good perhaps we
got a little cocky because just when we
thought the war was won a bunch of 20th
century physicists came to the party and
they revealed that the laws of the
universe the same laws that modern
cryptography was built upon they are as
we thought they were we thought that one
object couldn't be in two places at the
same time it's not the case we thought
nothing can possibly spin clockwise and
anti-clockwise simultaneously but that's
incorrect and we thought that two
objects on opposite sides of the
universe light-years away from each
other they can't possibly influence one
another instantaneously
we were wrong again and isn't that
always the way life seems to go just
when you think you've got everything
covered you got your ducks in a row a
bunch of physicists come along and
reveal that the fundamental laws of the
universe are completely different to
what you fill up and it screws
everything up see in the teeny tiny
subatomic realm at the level of
electrons and protons the classical laws
of physics the ones that we all know and
love they go out the window and it's
here that the laws of quantum mechanics
kick in in quantum mechanics an electron
can be spinning clockwise and
anti-clockwise at the same time and a
proton can be in two places at once it
sounds like science fiction but that's
only because the crazy quantum nature of
our universe it hides itself from us and
it stayed hidden from us and told the
20th century but now that we've seen it
the whole world is in an arms race to
try to build a quantum computer a
computer that can harness the power of
this weird and whacky quantum behavior
these things are so revolutionary and so
powerful that they'll make today's
fastest supercomputer look useless in
comparison in fact for certain problems
that are of great interest
today's fastest supercomputer is closer
to an abacus than to a quantum computer
that's right I'm talking about those
little wooden things with the beads
quantum computers can simulate chemical
and biological processes that are far
beyond the reach of our classical
computers and as such they promised to
help us solve some of our planet's
biggest problems they're going to help
us combat global hunger to tackle
climate change to find cures for
diseases and pandemics for which we've
so far been unsuccessful to create
superhuman artificial intelligence and
perhaps even more important in all of
those things they're going to help us
understand the very nature of our
universe but with this incredible
potential comes an incredible risk
remember remember those big numbers I
talked about earlier I'm not talking
about 851 in fact if anyone in here's
been distracted trying to find those
factors I'm gonna put you out of your
misery and tell you that it's 23 times
37 I'm talking about the much bigger
number that followed it well today's
fastest supercomputer couldn't find
those factors in the life age of the
universe a quantum computer could easily
factorize numbers way way bigger than
that one quantum computers will break
all of the encryption currently used to
protect you and I from hackers and
they'll do it easily let me put it this
way if quantum computing was a spear
then modern encryption the same
unbreakable system that's protected us
for decades it would be like a shield
made of tissue paper anyone with access
to a quantum computer will have the
master key to unlock anything they like
in our digital world they could steal
money from banks and control economies
they could power off hospitals or launch
nukes or they could just sit back and
watch all of us on our webcams without
any of us knowing that this is happening
now the fundamental unit of information
on all of the computers we're used to
this one it's called a bit a single bit
can be one of two states it can be a
zero or it can be a one when I FaceTime
my mum
from the other side of the world and
she's going to kill me for having this
slide we're actually just sending each
other long sequences of zeros and ones
that bounce from computer to computer
from satellite to satellite transmitting
our data at a rapid pace bits are
certainly very useful in fact anything
we currently do with technology is
indebted to the usefulness of bits but
we're starting to realize that bits are
really poor at simulating complex
molecules and particles and this is
because in some sense subatomic
processors can be doing two or more
opposing things at the same time as they
follow these bizarre rules of quantum
mechanics so late last century some
really brainy physicists had this
ingenious idea to instead build
computers that are founded on the
principles of quantum mechanics now the
fundamental unit of information of a
quantum computer it's called a qubit it
stands for quantum bit instead of having
just two states like zero or one a qubit
can be an infinite number of states and
this corresponds to it being some
combination of both
0 and 1 at the same time a phenomenon
that we call superposition and when we
have two qubits in superposition we're
actually working across all four
combinations of 0 0 0 1 1 0 and 1 1 with
3 qubits we're working in superposition
across eight combinations and so on each
time we add a single qubit we double the
number of combinations that we can work
with ensue purposes in superposition at
the same time and so when we scale up to
work with many qubits we can work with
an exponential number of combinations at
the same time and this just hints at
where the power of quantum computing is
coming from now in modern encryption our
secret Keys like the 2 factors of that
larger number they're just long
sequences of zeros and ones
to find them a classical computer must
go through every single combination one
after the other until it finds the one
that works and breaks our encryption but
on a quantum computer with enough qubits
in superposition information can be
extracted from all combinations at the
same time in very few steps a quantum
computer can brush aside all of the
incorrect combinations homing on the
correct one and then unlock our
treasured secrets now at the crazy
quantum level something truly incredible
is happening here the conventional
wisdom held by many leading physicists
and you've got to stay with me on this
one
is that each combination is actually
examined by its very own quantum
computer inside its very own parallel
universe each of these combinations they
add up like waves in a pool of water the
combinations that are wrong they cancel
each other out and the combinations that
are right they reinforce and amplify
each other so that at the end of the
quantum computing program all that's
left is the correct answer that we can
then observe here in this universe now
if that doesn't make complete sense to
you don't stress you're in good company
Niels Bohr one of the pioneers of this
field he once said that anyone who can
contemplate quantum mechanics without
being profoundly shocked they haven't
understood it but you get an idea of
what we're up against and why it's now
up to us cryptographers to really step
it up and we have to do it fast because
quantum computers they already exist in
labs all over the world fortunately at
this minute they only exist at a
relatively small scale still too small
to break down much larger cryptographic
keys but we might not be safe for long
some folks believe that secret
government agencies have already built a
big enough one
and they just haven't told anyone yet
some punters say they're more like 10
years off some people say it's more like
30 and you might think that if quantum
computers are 10 years away surely
that's enough time for us cryptographers
to figure it out and to secure the
Internet in time but unfortunately it's
not that easy even if we ignore the many
years that it takes to standardize and
deploy and then roll out new encryption
technology in some ways we may already
be too late smart digital criminals and
government agencies may already be
storing our most sensitive encrypted
data in anticipation for the quantum
future ahead the messages of foreign
leaders of war generals or of
individuals who question power their
encrypted for now but as soon as the day
comes that someone gets their hands on a
quantum computer they can retroactively
lis break anything from the past in
certain government and financial sectors
or in military organisations sensitive
data has got to remain classified for 25
years so if a quantum computer really
will exist in ten years then these guys
are already 15 years too late to quantum
proof their encryption so while many
scientists around the world are racing
to try to build a quantum computer ask
cryptographers are urgently looking to
reinvent encryption to protect us long
before that day comes we're looking for
new hard mathematical problems we're
looking for problems that just like
factorization can be used on our
smartphones and on our laptops today but
unlike factorization we need these
problems to be so hard that they're even
unbreakable with a quantum computer in
recent years we've been digging around
the much wider realm of mathematics to
look for such problems we've been
looking at numbers and objects that are
far more exotic and far more abstract
than the ones that you and I used to
like the ones on our calculators and we
believe we've found some geometric
problems that just might do the trick
now unlike those two and
three-dimensional geometric problems
that we used to have to try to solve
with pen and graph paper in high school
most of these problems are defined in
well
500 dimensions so not only are they a
little hard to depict and solve on graph
paper but we believe that even out of
the reach of a quantum computer so
though it's early days it's here that we
are putting our hope as we try to secure
our digital world moving into its
quantum future just like all of the
other scientists we cryptographers are
tremendously excited at the potential of
living in a world alongside quantum
computers they could be such a force for
good but know what no matter what
technological future we live in our
secrets will always be a part of our
humanity and that is worth protecting
Thanks
[Applause]